hey guys it is Friday which means I'm
here to get you all caught up on this
week's events in gaming news the latest
first up a new Xbox one update is on the
way xbox engineering lead Mike ibarra
took to Twitter to say that the next
update will be available first to those
using the preview program and that it
would arrive soon he added that not all
features of the upcoming update will be
in the first world they release through
the preview program Jabara didn't
clarify which features will be included
or whether the update he is referring to
is the xbox one anniversary update which
is due to launch in early June for
testers next up the first row said that
people are loving fallout 4 mods on Xbox
one it seems the numbers are well and
truly outpacing the popularity of mods
on Pacey as the publisher said Xbox
traffic was 50 times the initial flat
for PC mod launch adding we tried for 15
years and mods are finally on a console
fallout 4 xbox one mods are made on PC
using the Creation Kit it's worth noting
that you cannot earn achievements with
mods installed and there is a 2 gigabyte
cap on install mods the game also
creates a new save when you begin using
mods so if it all messes up you don't
lose progress fallout 4 mods are due to
hit Pierce port in June Elizabeth said
they might be making changes to the
overwatch characters McCree and my
current favorite diva designer Jeff
Goodman posted on the games forum where
he said makris flash bang and fan combo
plays an important role in being a
strong option against very fast as agile
teams traitors ganges etc that said it's
probably a bit too good at dealing
damage to higher health targets such as
tanks and barriers I don't have any
concrete changes yet but I'm going to be
testing some things internally to see
how he plays he added the diva is a
little bit too crap at dealing damage
right now and while this is a design
decision because she's also a quick tank
they are considering making improvements
to her just what they might alter
specific
it wasn't stifled I already covered this
story earlier this week but good Lord a
bit bear repeating EA were concerned
about setting battlefield one during
World War one because they were worried
that kids don't know the what happened I
can't figure out if this story makes me
more upset at EA or our schooling
systems but EA were legitimately worried
that many young consumers don't know
about World War 2 or Vietnam so they
wouldn't know about World War one
thankfully someone came to their senses
and we are getting a battlefield game
riddled with tanks and battleships
airplanes horses and world war one era
weaponry I've know about you but my
hopes are way up finally the witcher 3
got a massive update this week which is
added features and made a bunch of fix
the 1.2 update fixes an issue where
girls won't put his clothes back on
after sex scenes which I'm quietly
annoyed about but whatever there are
also a bunch of new additions like an
enemy upscaling option and assistance
make it easier to collect Gwent cards
developers said a pro x have released
the full list of patch notes you can
check out just what's changed in our
story on site also worth mentioning is
that the blood and wine expansion
arrived this week so if you have a bunch
of time up your sleeve you can get stuck
into the 30-hour romp with your now
appropriately clothed girls let me know
in that comment box if you've been
playing blood and wine and what you
think of this week's story this week on
site we talked about a new game of
thrones character show you how to kick
ass as all the characters in overwatch
and check out the best new mutagens into
witcher 3 is blood and one that is
everything I happy this week we are
jet-setting off to join our path in San
Francisco tomorrow so be sure to have
yourselves a great weekend and I will
catch you again from the land of the
free on Monday